in calculus one of the first things that
you learn to do with the derivative of
the function is to find the tangent of
an equation where the equation is curved
okay
because if indicate if the arc actually
graph you're going to draw this curve
the gradients always changing and so
this is a perfect use of the derivative
to find the gradient at a particular
point and use that to find the equation
of a tangent today's a pretty typical
question find the equation of the
tangent to that curve y equals minus x
squared plus X plus 2 at a particular
point when x equals 1 so how do we
approach this well you want to think
about what do you need to find the
equation of a tangent okay you want to
find the gradient of that tangent and
the point that it goes through right so
in other words you're gonna be using the
point gradient form for the equation of
a line right now we've already been
given the x coordinate here that will
correspond to the x1 so what we need to
find out here is two other pieces the
gradient of the tangent and the y
coordinate the y1 that the line passes
through okay now since we already have
the x coordinate we can work out the y
coordinate really quickly just by
substituting straight back in without an
x value into the equation okay so let's
do that first and then say when x equals
1 y is leaving soon and I'm just gonna
do a straight substitution here so that
I have my Y value that I've got a sub in
for later okay so I've got minus 1 plus
1 plus 2 these two cancel out centers
and number two okay so here's my X 1
he's my y1 now how I work at am that's
where the calculus comes in so I'm going
to need to differentiate this function
okay so given my equation for y I'm just
going to apply my straightforward
differentiation rules and you can see
- yeah plus one now that's the
expression there for the derivative okay
you kind of put that minus 2x plus 1
into here yeah I actually need a real
value for that okay so to do that I'm
gonna say again when x equals 1 what's
the derivative equal to it will be equal
to minus 2 here's my gradient okay so
now I have the pieces I need to actually
substitute into the equation I've got my
X 1 I've got my y 1
yeah and now I've also got this dy/dx at
this particular point that's the M that
I'm after
okay so I've used differentiation to
find that part now reduced it back down
to a problem that you and I didn't you
rate right how to work out the equation
of a line going to a particular point
with a particular gradient okay so all I
need to do is take that information and
somebody so the equation of the tangent
will be y -2 is my Y 1 value equals
minus 1 times X minus 1 okay so you can
see if I bring this is going to be minus
X plus 1 and if I bring that to overawe
this is minus X plus 3 okay now I'm done
one of the great things about calculus
is that when you have a result you can
test to see whether it's right or not
okay so in order to verify my result I'm
just gonna quickly sketch this down and
see if that is indeed the tangent
okay so in order to graph this I'm
probably gonna need to factorize this
guy up here that's going to be think
about your products you saw
that'll be 2 minus X plus 1 so from that
you can read off the intercepts right so
I will be going through negative 1 there
and positive 2 this is a parabola right
and my y-intercept for this problem will
be 2 so I don't expecting a vertex
halfway between so just to make it look
accurate and it'll be somewhere around
here okay now what's this going to look
like yeah alright now there's my
parabola now when I think about my
equation yeah
my straight line I'm going through the
y-axis at y plus 3 and I've got a
grating of minus 1 so when I think about
how this is going to look this is my
point here that I'm interested in
actually finding the tangent x equals 1
right that's where I got from the
question so when I think about how this
is going to look there's my equation and
I mean this graph is not perfect I don't
have the degree lines or anything but
you can see I'm in the right ballpark ok
and you can test your crazy map to make
sure that this equation and our original
equation minus x squared plus X plus 2
you can verify that they only have one
point of intersection you could solve
simultaneously or you could even use the
discriminant okay
so just to review how to find the
equation of a tangent take your original
equation and whatever information you've
been given and use that to fill out the
pieces all in this case the point
grading formula okay so you've been
given X 1 use X 1 some straight back in
together Y 1 and then to find the last
remaining
and you're going to need to
differentiate and then find the grading
at the specific spot that you're
interested in okay take all those pieces
of information sell them all in and
there's your equation of the tangent